el partido demócrata de Estados Unidos
retiene el control del senado tras la
victoria de Katherine Cortez masto en
Nevada en la cámara de representantes
los republicanos necesitan siete escaños
de los 20 que quedan por conocerse para
alcanzar la mayoría tenemos análisis en
esta edición
las fuerzas ucranianas avanzan en la
retoma de gerson tras La retirada de las
tropas rusas de la orilla occidental del
río nyaper fuelodimirse denunció que el
ejército de Moscú destruyó la
infraestructura crítica de la ciudad de
gerson antes de abandonarla
una explosión en Estambul causa al menos
seis muertos y más de 80 heridos el
presidente Turco declaró que información
preliminar apunta un ataque terrorista
Aunque en ningún grupo ha reivindicado
los hechos Tenemos reporte desde
Estambul
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
empezamos esta edición en Estados Unidos
porque el partido demócrata mantiene el
control del senado tras la victoria de
Katherine Cortez masto en el estado de
Nevada en la composición actual los
demócratas cuentan con 50 escaños y los
republicanos con 49 Todavía queda un
escaño al senado por decidirse en la
segunda vuelta del estado de Georgia del
6 de diciembre pero aunque lo ganen los
republicanos y la cámara alta quede
dividida en 50 a 50 el voto de la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris
desempataría y otorgaría la mayoría a
los demócratas ahora para analizar el
tema conectamos con Scott morgenstern
profesor de ciencias políticas en la
universidad de Pittsburgh Scott Buenas
tardes todavía Hay posibilidades de que
los demócratas obtengan mayoría en la
cámara de representantes
es posible sobre vida pero estamos
esperando los resultados entonces hay
como 20 curles que no han sido decididos
todavía pero pronto vamos a tener los
resultados va a ser muy empatados
entonces hay un si los publicanos ganan
van a tener mayoría muy estrecha y
precisamente si los republicanos ganan
la cámara de representantes que
escenarios se dibujaría para la
administración biden con un congreso
eventualmente dividido
algunas complicaciones importantes los
que ellos van a lanzar varios
investigaciones ya han dicho eso
dice que no sabe por qué Pero ellos
dicen que van a intentar ajustarlo pero
ellos no va en tucar tanto porque puede
ser bloqueado por el senado y entonces
no sólo es algo político para polinizar
aún más el sistema Pero hay otras cosas
muy importantes que ellos pueden
bloquear por ejemplo
la asistencia para Ucrania vamos a ver
si ellos van a apoyarlo o no entonces
hay otras cosas así que son muy
importantes no sigue con la mayoría y
con la mayoría ya declarada demócrata en
el senado todavía es relevante de alguna
manera la segunda vuelta de Georgia
Sí por supuesto porque ellos tienen más
posibilidades no tienen que contar con
una persona como hemos tenido en los
últimos dos años que un senador que este
Western que es más conservador Entonces
siempre ha sido un debate con él una un
intercambio difícil para que vea la
[__] a los otros demócratas entonces
tiene alguna persona más ayuda mucho a
los demócratas que devoción una cosa más
que el senado tiene poder de aprobar los
jueces entonces solo tener los 50 ahí
tener la mayoría ahí ayuda mucho a los
demócratas con este segundo la segunda
parte del mandato de baile
Scott murdersen estaremos muy pendientes
del avance de los resultados que quedan
como usted decía en la cámara de
representantes Muchas gracias por su
tiempo y por su análisis
Gracias a ti
vamos ahora con información relacionada
con la Guerra de Ucrania porque kiev
restablece su control sobre la ciudad de
jerson tras La retirada de las tropas de
Moscú recordemos que el viernes las
fuerzas especiales de Ucrania fueron las
primeras en entrar en la ciudad ayer
ingresaron policías autoridades
ucranianas y empezó a llegar ayuda
humanitaria Es que según el pueblo
dimirsele el ejército ruso destruyó la
infraestructura crítica de la urbe antes
de abandonarla y movilizar todas sus
tropas en una línea de defensa la orilla
Oriental del río niéper distintos
analistas consideran La retirada rusa de
jerson una táctica de Cara a una posible
negociación más detalles de la situación
con lluis Muñoz
banderas ucranianas en gerson Jeff logra
la recuperación de una de las provincias
anexionadas por Rusia un lugar
estratégico para poder reconquistar
parte del territorio perdido tras la
invasión de Rusia
en el sur y también no solo sobre crimea
y las fuerzas rusas allí sino también
sobre la flota rusa del mar Negro
armas a distancia principalmente al
alcance una cantidad significativa del
territorio ucraniano que Rusia posee
actualmente
con la recuperación de jerson el
ejército ucraniano buscará después del
duro invierno llegar a las ciudades de
mérito Paul y Mario Paul para ello deben
cruzar al margen Oriental del río nieper
donde Rusia ha montado su línea de
defensa con el abandono de jerson el
ejército ruso trata de reagruparse Y
aprovechar la Barrera natural del río y
evitar que Ucrania pueda cortar su
conexión terrestre con crimea en
palabras para France 24 el analista
Fernando cocho intuye tres posibilidades
en las intenciones del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin Pero hay tres por
visibilidades que están barajando en
todos los análisis de inteligencia Y
seguridad uno que abandona gerson como
una especie de Berlín los años 40 para
ser la ciudad a partir de la cual se
pueda negociar con Ucrania un fin de la
guerra bajo la presión de Estados Unidos
China India entre otros una segunda
variante sería que se ha refugiado en
más en el profundo bombas Putin porque
son tampoco lo necesitaba desde el punto
de vista geoestratégico y la tercera que
pretenda dar una señal hacia Ucrania que
le haga bajar sus exigencias a la hora
de una negociación tras la invasión de
Rusia Ucrania del 24 de febrero Rusia
logró el control de gerson tras un
ataque Relámpago casi 8 meses después
kiev logra recuperar un territorio que
está lejos de la normalidad tras haber
sido minado saqueado y cuya
infraestructura clave ha sido destruida
vamos ahora a la ciudad turca de
Estambul donde se produjo una explosión
que causó al menos seis muertos y más de
80 heridos a esta hora se desconocen
detalles de los hechos pero el
presidente del país
receptogan declaró que según información
preliminar parece un ataque bomba sin
embargo de momento ninguna organización
ha reivindicado los hechos que tuvieron
lugar en la avenida ispical en el centro
de la ciudad en una zona concurrida
tanto por locales como por turistas
nuestro corresponsal en Estambul adrià
Rocha con los detalles según ha
explicado el presidente Turco este
ataque ha sido un atentado terrorista
dicho el mismo y ha explicado sé que que
se va a castigar a los autores de este
ataque que no han sido capturados porque
según se puede ver en las cámaras de
seguridad que han sido filtradas a la
prensa turca una persona habría colocado
una bolsa con explosivas en un banco de
la calle descitlán y al después de que
esta semana se marchase del lugar esta
bolsa habría sido detonada ahí entre los
heridos hay imágenes terroríficas en las
redes sociales turcas entre los muertos
y heridos habría niños y menores de edad
Perdona han explicado en su rueda de
prensa esta misma tarde unas horas
después del atentado que se espera que
este ataque sea terrorista ha dicho que
huele a terrorismo aunque no ha podido
confirmarlo después de decir que los
autores de este ataque serán castigados
y ha dicho que una mujer según el
presidente Turco tendría habría tenido
un gran rol en este ataque se sabe muy
poquito más de lo que ha podido ocurrir
exactamente porque Turquía después de
este atentado ha decretado un bloqueo
informativo al atentado prohibido los
medios trucos que hablen y publiquen
información sobre este ataque si no es
información oficial que llegue
directamente del gobierno derecho
Después de esta prohibición se ha
bloqueado y restringido el acceso a las
grandes redes sociales como es Twitter
Instagram y YouTube
me dan una serie un refugiado político
iraní que vivió más de 18 años en el
aeropuerto de París o así sal de gold
falleció ahí en el mismo aeropuerto este
sábado tras ser rechazado por varios
países europeos nacery hizo del
aeropuerto su residencia en 2004 Steven
spielberg hizo una película inspirada en
su historia la terminal merán hacer y
vivió unos años fuera del aeropuerto en
un albergue después de caer enfermo pero
decidió regresar a la terminal en sus
últimos días Gabriel colchen nos cuenta
su historia
su apodo era así Alfred y era una de las
personas sin hogar más conocidas en el
mundo Megan nacer y murió este sábado en
el aeropuerto de Oasis donde vivió más
de 18 años allá todo el mundo lo conocía
cuando me lo dijeron se me soltaron las
lágrimas y me dio penas tenía su
banquillo y era su casa tenía todas sus
pertenencias etcétera
me han nacer era un refugiado político
iraní con 20 años se fue de su país en
búsqueda de su madre pero considerado
como un enemigo político nunca pudo
regresar sin papeles fue expulsado de
Alemania Reino Unido Italia
creo que nadie puede vivir 11 años en
una situación así he apelado a dos tres
cuatro gobiernos en esta situación soy
un caso único de inmigración
llegó al aeropuerto de París en 1988 con
43 años sin saber que se quedaría
vine de Bélgica pero no pude volver allí
en Francia se negaron a expedir el nuevo
estatus de refugiado político entonces
me quedé en tránsito a veces en
detención a veces fuera de detención
luego en el aeropuerto me liberaron
tenía un billete de avión a Londres pero
me negaron la entrada en 1999 Francia
finalmente le ofreció el estatus de
refugiado pero me harán nacer y decidió
quedarse en el aeropuerto recibía su
correo allí era seguido por un médico y
había ganado la confianza de los
trabajadores del Terminal
Mi destino ha sido ser aislado tanto
ayer como hoy inspiró la película la
terminal de Steven spielberg de 2004
protagonizada por Tom hanks algo que le
hizo ganar decenas de miles de dólares y
le permitió vivir unos años fuera del
aeropuerto pero hace unas semanas había
vuelto para terminar sus días allí
el activismo climático volvió a llamar
la atención sobre la emergencia
planetaria en un museo esta vez
activistas del grupo futuro vegetal
lanzaron jarabe y jugo de remolacha
sobre vitrinas y Marcos de cuadros en el
Museo egipcio de Barcelona el grupo
declaró que los materiales utilizados
simbolizan la gasolina y la sangre una
referencia a la relación entre el uso de
los combustibles fósiles y la crisis
climática recordemos que en estos
momentos representantes internacionales
se reúnen en Egipto donde se desarrolla
la Cumbre de Naciones Unidas para el
clima la crop-27 según global witness
también asisten al evento 636 lo vistas
de las Industrias fósiles
y cuatro ciclistas argentinos
recorrieron unos Diez mil kilómetros
pedaleando desde Sudáfrica hasta Qatar
Para apoyar a su selección nacional el
grupo de amigos utilizó sus redes
sociales para narrar el recorrido veamos
el informe de Andrés triviño
la locura mundialista Ya está presente
en Qatar un grupo de cuatro amigos
argentinos aventuró a recorrer 10.000
kilómetros desde Sudáfrica hasta Qatar
todo con un solo objetivo apoyar a su
selección doblemente mundialista
el Cuarteto argentino realizó un
recorrido de 177 días pedaleando casi
unos seis meses hasta llegar a doha El
desafío mayor fue el último que fue
cruzar el desierto de Arabia Saudita
tengo que hacer 2000 kilómetros
hicimos más o menos 150 kilómetros por
día y era levantarse comer algo y
desayunar salir a la ruta además de
realizar este arduo recorrido el equipo
de toda pedal buscaba romper los
estereotipos sobre las personas de los
países por los que pasaban mientras
grababan imágenes para realizar un
documental Este es el último de una
serie de viajes de larga distancia que
los ciclistas han realizado para asistir
a importantes eventos deportivos como
los Juegos Olímpicos de Río 2016 y el
mundial de Rusia 2018 una aventura
increíble más que una aventura fue una
una escuela de vida pues impresionante
todas las cosas que hemos vivido todavía
no no procesamos no nos damos cuenta no
dimensionamos de de lo que hemos logrado
el equipo utilizó las redes sociales
para narrar su recorrido diario y pedir
ayudas a sus seguidores al llegar a doha
cientos de aficionados los esperaban
para animar su último tramo mientras el
comité de organización y legado de la
FIFA les daba la bienvenida después de
recorrer 10.000 kilómetros en bicicleta
cruzando África y medio oriente los
argentinos de todo a pedal llegaron a
Qatar Para apoyar a su elección en la
copa del mundo ahora el equipo de
ciclista se prepara para ver el debut de
su selección contra Arabia Saudita el 22
de noviembre en Los Ángeles Stadium
hasta aquí esta edición informativa pero
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda esta y
más información en nuestras redes
sociales en nuestra página web Franz
24.com Y por supuesto aquí en nuestra
cadena enseguida volvemos
[Música]